do you want to hear a secret hold on
before i quench your curiosity let me
remind you that some things are better
off left not knowing cry around long
enough and you're sure to find something
you weren't looking for that is to say
not every treasure chest is filled with
gold coins elegant jewelry and expensive
relics maybe it's not even a treasure
chest at all dumpsters do look quite
similar don't they peek inside and you
might find rotting meat and a smell that
stings your nostrils so do you want to
hear a secret now
of course you do no disclaimer could
stand in the way of humanity and hot
gossip look at the world around you
everything revolves around information
the more we know the more we can say and
is there anything people want more than
something to say next time you're at a
nice restaurant with a group of friends
or co-workers or family look across from
you and notice how hard lips have to
refrain from belting out interjecting or
adding to sense humans can't help but
throw their words into the universe as
if they will echo in importance for
eternity some might say that listening
is a skill however you can't argue that
it is simply a prerequisite to speaking
it is a deal we make a compromise
if we listen then we get to speak if we
hear a secret we get to share it so we
spend our lives listening observing and
gathering information about the people
places and things around us philosophers
and scientists like to call it the
pursuit of truth but who are we kidding
it's a chore a task completed only for
the prize that comes with it the chance
to speak about what we've seen heard and
learned most often this journey of
gathering information isn't as profound
as we pretend it is digging around other
people's business is no noble task but
curiosity is like a shiny shovel and to
let a tool like this rust in the shed
would be a sin wouldn't it so with that
said let's stop pretending we don't love
tmz let's indulge in our lust for
secrets let's get digging deep into the
mystery of scp-1903
like with understanding any artifact
culture or ideology we have to first
look at the earliest origins of our
subject to comprehend its current state
this is to say
scp-1903 wasn't always
scp-1903 once upon a time she was jackie
jackie barter a woman who dedicated
herself to her job trying to make a
better life for herself jackie barter
valued her work above anything else she
did her job and never complained she
showed up early and always smiled
whether she enjoyed it however was
another thing it's hard to know anyone's
true feelings at their workplace but we
can speculate that her clients enjoyed
it more so what was it that she did
exactly for work what was her job title
when she filed taxes what did her
day-to-day shift look like
if only it was that easy
she handled her responsibilities behind
closed doors and there was an agreement
between her her clients and her boss mr
donner not to speak of what happened
behind said doors in a way these
customers were paying for privacy at the
same time and maybe more importantly
they were paying for jackie jackie
barter was one of the primary reasons
why mr donner was a success
sure he had a knack for business he knew
how to operate in the shadows of an
amenity he knew how to turn a profit but
most importantly he knew what his
clients wanted and what they wanted was
jackie but what exactly did she do what
was she offering why did they want her
the tight-lipped donner never made those
easy questions to answer however what we
do know is that she was in the
service industry and she wasn't bringing
food or drinks to her clients jackie
barter herself was enough for them she
brought her energy her smile her
personality her charm
and her glow she dressed in a white
dress and wore novelty bunny ears the
wardrobe never changed they never had to
while customers came to donner's
establishment to mix things up from
their normal lives when they were there
they didn't want change they wanted the
same thing each time they knew what they
wanted and it was jackie butter jackie
barter in a white dress and bunny ears
what she actually did however isn't as
clear but if you were to speculate you'd
likely come to some version of the truth
what is clear is who she did it for a
man who we will refer to as af was her
top client af managed the chemical plant
a few blocks from the establishment he
had a wife a high income job and had the
means to live a good life he had things
going for him everything he could ever
want but like any man built of vices he
wanted more mr donner's establishment
was made for people like af it was a
place where people could be influenced
by the devil on their left shoulder and
not be judged for it it was a place for
depravity detached from morality it was
a place where you didn't have to shape
your behavior to the expectations of
society family or friends more than that
it was a place where people themselves
didn't feel guilty for what they did mr
donner created a place where people
could act on their impulses enjoy
themselves walk out go home and leave
their shame at the door af loved every
aspect of it and so he became a local he
went frequently and he always requested
jackie donner operated his business in a
vague mysterious building the type of
place you'd have to yelp three times
before entering just to make sure you're
at the right address it looked abandoned
and yet you could feel the life behind
those doors it pulled you in inside
there were rooms lined up like a hotel
hallway behind one of those particular
doors waited not just one man but rather
a crew of friends af always brought
about three or four people with him why
he brought them isn't understood did he
feel safer in his sins when he shared
with others or was it that he was trying
to impress them or maybe he was up to no
good and wanted to have the numbers on
his side what we do know is that whoever
these men were af had an abundance of
them each time he visited the
establishment he brought a different
group of people with him but the
variance ended there because each time
his request was exactly the same the
woman dressed in white he wanted jackie
and only jackie she was his preferred
handler the reasons for this aren't
clear it might be as simple as a man
having a specific taste they might have
gotten along quite well or maybe there's
more to it maybe he was up to something
why he chose her we don't know but we do
know he loved his time with jackie
little did he know his time with her was
running out soon she would be someone or
something entirely new
scp-1903
what happened that night behind closed
doors we aren't sure but don't let that
stop you from speculating after af
returned home his wife went to donar's
establishment looking for information no
different than you are seeking
information right now listening closely
waiting for the next bomb to drop only
she wasn't at her computer she was
actively fighting for it donner being a
man dedicated to privacy kept his mouth
shut and sent her away but af's wife
didn't give up she knew something was
off and so she tracked jackie down after
hours unlike her confrontational
encounter with donner she was able to
ease into a friendly conversation with
jackie and coax information out of her
slowly but surely jackie opened up and
told her everything she told her all
about af's late nights spent there at
donner's establishment and about the men
he'd bring with them more specifically
jackie explained to her what happened
the night in question and whatever it
was it was enough for jackie not to come
in the next day and in the days
following that's when everything changed
for jackie over the course of the next
few days
she painfully morphed into what we see
her to be now
scp-1903 it started in her face nothing
that wouldn't concern anyone at first
glance her cheeks turned slightly pink
but the symptoms wouldn't be overlooked
for long she developed claw like hands
and feet the skin on her face turned
into what looks like a paper mache
styled rabbit mask her bunny ears no
longer were just for show but rather
they are entirely responsible for her
ability to hear she began to produce
mercury and blood through the pores of
her hands and feet no longer was she
jackie barter the foundation stepped in
and took her into their own custody and
deemed her scp-1908
this however did not come without
consequence for the foundation the
discovery of
scp-1903 and the knowledge obtained and
passed along should not have been
celebrated but they didn't know this
until the party had already started and
when the balloons began to pop it was
already too late let this be a lesson be
careful of the secrets you tell unlike
most curiosities this one came at a cost
no contestant on the price's right could
ever have guessed we are creatures who
crave information and we will dig around
until we get it and once retrieved it is
instinct to hold it up and show it to
the world mostly this is innocuous
however sometimes when someone spills
the tea
we all get burned
and that is exactly what happened
scp-1903 was discovered by the
foundation to harbor a slow-acting info
hazard the effects of this info hazard
are triggered when the subject learns
three important details of jackie's
story number one af's full name number
two af's actions towards jackie and
number three jackie's response to af's
actions sorry lebron bosh and wade but
no big three in nba history has ever
been as powerful as this one it is the
catalyst for years of damage if not
guarded properly it has the force to
dismantle entire dynasties as the
foundation spread this information
throughout personnel so spread the
infection across the research team
anyone who learned too much of the story
was and will be afflicted but what
exactly does that look like well
subjects will begin showing symptoms of
mercury poisoning and large parts of the
skin will flake off exclusively around
the facial area two days after exposure
to the trigger information after five
days typically when the pigmentation of
the affected area is pure white in color
the dermis will begin to form a
protective layer of similar composition
to
scp-1903's mask with the exclusion of
any traces of mercury this layer will
continue to form until it covers the
entire facial area and will eventually
appear to resemble a paper mache animal
mask of a similar fashion to scp-1903's
which typically resembles rabbits cats
wolves foxes and rats they will go
biologically deaf and they will only be
able to hear if they continue to wear
these ears over the course of this
change the hands and feet will undergo a
pigmentation shift darkening
considerably their nails will sharpen
growing into claws over time and the
subject's hearing will transfer to the
next set of novelty ears which represent
the animal that their masks resemble
once subjects have found these ears they
will show reluctance to take them off it
is unclear if this is because they have
built a bond with their identity or if
it is simply the case of them trying to
preserve their hearing furthermore if a
pair of ears becomes damaged to the
point where repair without spare parts
is impossible the subject will become
permanently deaf and they will be left
wishing their deafness had come sooner
saving them from hearing jackie's secret
saving them from the curse that comes
with it maybe they even wish to be mute
too because once an affected subject
tells a non-affected subject about the
trigger information the normal subject
will undergo the changes the affected
subject went through up until that point
thus continuing this chain of
unfortunate fate two to three days later
blood will begin to seep through the
pores in the subject's hands feet and
gums within a few hours mercury will
begin to appear in the subject's
bloodstream this does not physically
affect the subject or other subjects in
a similar state however it does severely
affect the subject's mental health many
afflicted subjects have been reported to
go to extreme measures to remove the
mask that has overtaken their face af
was one of them he sought at it with a
knife until his face was
well faceless
this means of infection by way of
infohazard was most notably observed
with researcher hayward when he was
reading revision 2 of scp-1903
by the time he finished he saw
scp-1903 staring at him from across the
cell through the observatory window she
was trying to warn him not to read it
she didn't say anything but she shushed
him he pressed the button for a
photograph and tried to talk to her
through the intercom but when he did she
just sat back down on her cot he assumed
that she realized he was reading her
file and then tried to warn him not to
tell anyone while the story of
scp-1903 was going around infecting
people and causing them intense physical
and psychological pain
scp-1903 herself was trying to save them
from it this is the tragic through line
of the story jackie barter spent her
whole life making other people feel
better in most cases this meant
sacrificing her time and energy to do so
and her payment for these services
wasn't fair what did she get she was
sentenced to life under strict
supervision a life in pain a life in a
body that isn't her own but this is
often overlooked the most documented and
studied pain wasn't of scp-1903
but rather the personnel who were
affected by her story in fact there are
few documented records of how scp-1903
itself feels however we have interviews
with researcher hayward explaining how
he felt after being affected and maybe
with time as hayward moves further and
further away from his time as a normal
human being we will begin to disregard
his pain too
in science empathy often finds a way to
elude us with each new study we move
closer to an objective understanding but
at the cost of traveling further and
further from its emotional makeup
regarding hayward he initially felt fine
after the affliction but in a couple of
hours the affected areas started to feel
irritated nothing that couldn't be
managed though he didn't think much of
it until the second day by then it felt
like he had spent the day on the beach
staring up at the hot sun but he
remembers not having been in the sun at
all that day even under a layer of
clouds and low temperatures the skin on
his face felt to have been roasting as
if in the oven his face was slowly
peeling off if he tugged at the corner
he swore would have ripped off like a
band-aid the pain and discomfort didn't
end there the testing for mercury wasn't
much fun either for him however he was
quite reluctant to go into details about
how the procedure was done similar to
how your dad would respond if you asked
him about his colonoscopy
even now hayward's face is still tender
a gentle kiss on the cheek would feel
like a pinch but the worst pain wasn't
physical it was the mental games it
played with his head he experienced
hallucinations he started seeing them
around the time he noticed that the mask
finished growing they blended with
reality and it took him time to start
recognizing their onset he could tell he
was hallucinating if he focused on
people's clothing because in his
hallucinations their outfits would
change until everyone was wearing a
white tux or a white evening gown the
dresses would be classy yet revealing
similar to how the woman would dress at
donner's establishment in fact most
everything in the hallucinations could
be called back to donners the people in
the hallucinations would be wearing
masks of different animal types just
like jackie and her co-workers hayward
said it looked like a masquerade where
he was the center of attention everyone
would turn their heads to face him even
if their necks should have snapped
they'd turn a full 180 and they would
just blare
these hallucinations would last close to
30 seconds and during that half minute
one thing stood out specifically there
would be a man leaning against the wall
not wearing a mask he was the only one
who wasn't in stylish evening wear so he
kind of sticks out
he can't be made out clearly but by
studying the description the foundation
believes it to be a vision of donner
could donner be a more important piece
to this story than we give him credit
the person trying hardest to silence the
story must have the most skin in the
game of secrets right either way we can
all learn a lesson from donner and keep
quiet from time to time i will say it
again sometimes when someone spills the
tea
we all get burned
now go check out
scp-3887 monster under the bed in the
horror of body stealing rain scp-3300
for more haunting anomalies that'll stay
with you forever